it's not an instrument that you can sort
of like can I pick up them get a decent
sound out if that's the hard part
yeah but violin would be the same way
like you know it takes a long time of
learning it to even make anything that
sounds good at all
twice on a piano and it would keep
playing a couple courts and at least is
it - it's not like an oboe or where you
play with the breathe in your mouth the
reed it's down here but not has nothing
to do with the reed on using supply
inherited leads these two here are
called the tender guards and this is the
base camp and these play a note that's
an octave below the second lowest note
on here and then this plays an octave
below even days made out of African
Blackwood and this is just a great
elephant angry that you can't get pipes
with that anymore of course it's off but
these are from 1910 the second the 1910
and made it Scotland and that's the
other bag the bankers were lemons of
course and it's made out of sheepskin
this is the cover yeah it's a sheepskin
bag in that's of course